[Music]
then we moved to chicago and i think we
were producing for another three or four
years oh great maybe three and what's
your memory of that time i'm sure you
had no money oh no no well where were
you living we were sleeping in the back
of the theater wow on a little futon
uh eating beans well i would make a big
pot of beans
no lime no never lame but yeah just a
big pot of beans and i would just i
would i remember you know just walking
past the pot of beans dipping my coffee
mug in it and just and just not even
breaking stride and going on building
the sets and doing doing everything and
as far as
looking back now on on a kind of
happiness scale did you was that a fun
time was that was it everything it was
everything if we had a couple of shows
that didn't sell we would go homeless
because we were living there too so the
pressure was kind of immense
but i just remember it as being a very
intense time
harmonize with me and hold me back all
through the night you're shining bright
i'm your boy
[Music]